so my first question was that obviously
the the story of this this series or at
least Kim philby he's one of the most
notorious double agents in all of
history and as an American this was not
a story that I was entirely familiar
with so at all before you joined this
project were you familiar with any of
the the details of it well I I was only
uh uh familiar with the Cambridge five I
knew about Kim philby and I knew some of
the other names uh of those five
um and I'd seen
um a number of
shows and films that have been made
about those five but uh I didn't really
know in any depth uh any details about
them as as characters and people other
than what was presented on screen so it
was quite a journey for me to sort of
dig in and and
um and understand you know get try to
understand philby more and and I
certainly didn't know anything about
Nicholas Elliott and and so that was a
very interesting part of the story to to
really get a sense of their friendship
because often in the in the things that
we've seen before
the the drama and the and the Intrigue
is about the is Spy World and that and
that you know lives and deaths there you
know it's life and death stuff and and
lives are at stake and and countries are
at War and that it's all quite Big Stuff
whereas this had a lovely sense of
intimacy and friendship and the Betrayal
of friendship about it that so it was
great to sort of try and dig into some
of those details and and understand
these people as people
um as well as being spies uh this show
is obviously based on a book and you're
you're playing real people but in what
sense
how much are you able to research and
rely on that and at what point do you
kind of just have to stop and say you
know this is all on me now I can only
the research can only take me so far
especially with something with playing
real people who are in MI5 or SAS where
you know obviously some of the details
aren't going to be publicly available
yeah I mean well that's so there comes a
point doesn't that where you kind of
have to put the whole homework down and
actually then get on your feet and do it
you know so it's at a different point on
on age job I find yeah I think that's
right you know you just
once once you've done all your research
and all your reading and you hope that
somehow you've absorbed parts of that
but then then it's very animalistic it's
very instinctive and responsive once
you've had up on set things change
all the times you could be ready just to
keep moving and changing with everything
whilst having a sort of firm
understanding of who your character is
that's uh yeah that's the that that's
the sort of switchover point and you you
two play characters that are so closely
intertwined over such a long period of
time so in terms of working together
they'd still be an ellioter on such a
razor edge both when they first meet all
the way up through you know everything
in Beirut and Beyond so how did you guys
go about finding that balance together
as actors well I think you just it's
just a natural process I mean you you
it doesn't to me it doesn't feel like we
had to go out of our way to come up with
something in order to find it it you
know so much is there in the script so
much is there in just all the
discussions that begin uh not just
between Damien and and I but but
obviously with Nick our director and
with Alex our writer
um and and and questions come up and and
I think yeah for me I find I'm then
going home each night and kind of
imagining this and imagining that and
and how I might play this and how I
might play that and you know we had we
had a you know a little bit of time
before we started to to sort of get to
know each other and just to get to know
this piece that we were working on
um and I I think you know Damien and I
clicked fairly easily when we when we
met so it wasn't like we were trying to
fit a square peg into a round hole
um
so that was the experience for me it it
it it it it it evolved quite naturally
there was you know there was so much
dialogue for this in in this for me and
for Damien as well I mean I I and I have
to spend a lot of time learning dialogue
so that's really where all my sort of my
focus was and and as Damien says when
you're on set together you're ready for
things to change and you're also I'm
also was ready just for the spontaneity
of the energy within a scene you know
for that to just live and breathe it
right there and then and and you know
you find lovely delicate moments that
might actually be quite meaningful that
you didn't necessarily even imagine when
you read the same 12 times before you've
done it but it's just suddenly come
alive in that moment so
um you know that's that's what you
direct us for and that's what Alex is
for and that's what the pair of us were
sort of keeping tabs on as well just
just just knowing that that then feeling
like that stuff that we were um
inhabiting was was what we thought it
was when we read the script and for
either of you is it do you think it's
more difficult to play someone to play a
real person as opposed to somebody
that's made up entirely on the page or
just because you're working with
something that's already fictionalized
is it not really make a difference I
enjoy playing real people there's a
responsibility
I think there's an added responsibility
to get it right to honor them uh
uh in a truthful way
but I've played real people a bunch of
times and um it it it it means it has a
it's a history so it's actually a fun
history lesson you go read read around
them find out what they're doing what
they did why they killed people if
they're Killers uh
uh and
um
and then of course you have to just
in the end what we actors always have to
do is just play the script there's if
you're fighting against the script try
and play things that just aren't there I
think you just end up with a clash you
don't know with a clash of all kinds of
different things so in the end you've
gotta you gotta just come back to the
script yeah you're sort of trying to do
I find that I'm I'm always going what
what is it that you want from me and I'm
saying this to the script I'm saying
this to the writer I'm saying this to
the director how can I honor what it is
that you want let me try and understand
what it is that you want and and see if
I can facilitate that and obviously
there are you know a couple of times
where I go Oh that's oh I wouldn't have
thought that and you might have some
some discussions about stuff but yeah
generally I find my task our task is to
is to honor that script as Damon says so
so if you sort of go off on a tangent
and you're trying to do something else
then then there's a clash of a clash of
ideas and this this show is at least to
me was kind of very deliberately
confusing it's pushing you in a bunch of
different directions and you end up at a
point where you kind of almost don't
know where the truth really lies it's
sort of in a gray area in the middle so
when it comes to working on a project
like that how do you sort of go about
keeping things straight because I know
from a technical perspective you're
you're shooting things in a certain
order and that might make it a little
easier but did it in terms of these
characters emotional lives like how do
you go about keeping things straight
when the story is not really giving you
everything so to speak It's Tricky too
on a job like this because you're
playing characters who are duplicitous
and who are lying and who are sort of
saying one thing and meaning something
else so
uh you know I
had this been a different director I'm
not sure I would have been able to take
it on to be honest but I'd worked with
Nick before and really trusted his
um view of things and I really relied
heavily on that as well as relying on
Damien and relying on Alex you know the
three of them together were a wonderful
team of sort of heads that that uh that
that had a great perspective on this
whole thing so
I'm quite reliant on other people
yeah it's the best way to be great
I don't need to tell you how to do it
I'll do it yeah
yeah and why why do you think the story
is relevant now like what what appealed
to you about doing it now whether it's
something that you know if it relates to
you know current politics now or the way
the world is now what what kind of Drew
you to this story I think it does relate
to politics now but I
I think far more interestingly right at
the center of this is is a is a is a
conversation about faith and love
and the risks we take when we love
people
you you know we will you never know
another human being
you know even in marriage you'll never
fully know another human being and I
think if there's a big betrayal at the
end uh maybe just in a romantic
relationship that you've had in this
case a 30-year relationship of best
friends uh
um I think the damage that it does to
people who have been betrayed is
profound you ask yourself all kinds of
questions about how about your part in
it your role in it did I contribute
somehow how did this happen and so I
think that's what this show is about and
I think it's I I said in the spy uh
world with a thriller framework uh
whereas guy just said everybody's lying
to everybody is anything ever as it
seems and so reality is heightened
immediately that's a very exciting place
to be as a viewer it's like oh God who's
telling the truth who's lying and uh
lives are at stake and uh
sort of great
intimate personal betrayals but
betrayals on a political geopolitical
global scale are happening at the same
time so everything is already very
heightened and right at the center of
that is just this very intimate betrayal
and I uh I think that's why the I think
that's where the show sits in its sweet
spot you know uh
it's imagine being betrayed
or or managing to betray everybody
for 30 whole years incredible when
you're seeing them working with them
every day that's our story they mean at
one point you described Elliot as being
kind of like a peacock or a hawk and I
do see a lot of that sort of in him in
this show so guy I had a question for
you if you had to describe Kim philby
with an animal which one do you think
you'd pick well he's got some sort of
catalog quality maybe it's a sort of
Slinky black Puma or something like that
I'm not I don't know
yeah maybe a cat but it really kind of
you know
a really Charming One Direction yeah not
a not a crazy one so
in total what do you hope people sort of
take away from the story whether it's
you know the idea the fact is Stranger
Than Fiction or or what have you well I
think it's Damian says you know the the
it sort of looks at at love and the and
the
the idea of you know the links will go
to to protect each other as friends and
and then the the the the fragility of
that and and how
um how devastating that can be when the
Friendship is betrayed so you know I
whether it's what people take away from
it but hopefully it's what people
connect to when they watch it that you
know that
because everybody has friends and
everybody has questions about their
friends and everybody has probably been
Betrayed at some point by their friends
um
to whatever degree even on the on a sort
of small scale so I'm sure people will
be able to relate to that you know just
because as Damian says this is set in
sort of spy world and
um uh it doesn't mean that it I'm I'm
sure that will be intriguing for a lot
of people because that's not the world
that a lot of people live in but you
know that's great exciting stuff to
watch but the idea of sort of friends
working together in that world is
something that probably people could
relate to thank you both so much for
talking to me today it was an honor